- We are here in the Emirates, in Dubai,
on my camel farm.
I am actually from Germany.
It was never in my mind to breeding camel;
it just came by chance.
(upbeat electronic music)
- Wherever I am in the world,
food is the focal point
of everything I do.
My name is Ching, and I'm
a chef and food writer.
My taste journeys have
taken me all over the world,
in search of great
flavors and new recipes.
Finally, it has brought me to Dubai.
And I can't wait to explore
its rich and varied food scene.
One bite at a time.
(curious electronic beat)
I've come to meet Uschi, a camel breeder
whose kept all the traditions
of Emirati flavors alive
year after year since moving
her from Germany in 1988.
- Nice to have you here, nice.
- How are you?
- I am fine, fine.
Welcome, welcome.
- Thank you.
- What I saw that time,
especially the city here in Dubai,
already it was very beautiful.
Much different than to other countries.
You cannot have a better
place as a woman than here.
Emirati culture is very respectful,
and very open-minded.
(gentle music)
First when I came as tourist,
I loved the country, I see,
I feel there is something.
In the early days I met this local family
and I fell in love with the family--
- So the Emirati culture is full of love,
I feel, and openness, and heart.
- Yeah, and what the family give to me,
I give now to the people from outside,
and I want to give it to you.
- Thank you, that's amazing.
That's amazing, thank you.
(both laugh)
- Many people have not the
chance to meet local people
and to know the real tradition,
and that's why I love being a host,
and people who coming to me,
they keep me going and going and going.
- Hello, he's hungry. (laughs)
He's found the food.
- This is the big grains,
this also al ain dates.
This is like dessert to him.
- Forget the main course,
he's got a sweet tooth.
- Yeah, not getting too much.
- [Ching] So, their meat
is really prized, isn't it?
- Yes, it's the lowest
cholesterol of any kind of meat,
and also very low fat,
much lower than cow.
Emirati families, if they
not have camel for raising
or for competition, they will not sell it,
but they will have it
for the whole family.
- [Ching] I see.
- See, you can touch the
nose, how soft, like handsome.
- Oh, hello sweetheart.
She's gorgeous.
What I learned from Uschi is
that it's about using very
simple, humble ingredients,
but cooked with love,
each with its different traditions,
to really give you that
Bedouin and desert experience.
I've just broken it, I've just broken it.
Yeah, it's okay?
(man speaking foreign language)
Ooh, it's hot, hot.
Mmm, that is really good.
(man speaking foreign language)
I think I'm hired. (laughs)
- My earliest memory of cooking,
the using different spices
and different preparing.
I eat my first goat leg here.
(spices sizzling in pan)
It needs two hours before
to make the fire ready,
an the preparation in between,
and then two hours to cook it.
This makes the difference.
(Arabic music)
- [Ching] The goat was amazing.
Such a simple, but humble, ritual;
it tasted so good; I
loved every minute of it.
- [Uschi] We have here
la hambush, camel meat.
In the spices it's just
simple salt and black pepper.
- Mm, that is so good.
The fact that people have
been sitting in the desert
for thousands of years like
this, it's so beautiful.
I've had such a magical day.
- Yes, I hope so, and you
are a wonderful guest.
- [Ching] Oh, thank you, Uschi.
Uschi is the queen of the desert,
who knows that her heart
belongs here in Dubai.
She is a true Bedouin, a free spirit.
And she knows how to really deliver
Emirati hospitality.
(Arabic music)